Hello everybody.
Hello.
Oh my gosh.
Valentine's Day.
Yo.
Oh my gosh.
Welcome to my, uh, I decided this on a whim, my impromptu
Valentine's karaoke.
Because I won't really be able to do a proper stream on
Valentine's Day, sad.
Um, but yeah, uh, we're here for, for, for the vibes that
we're here to get so, so, oh my Oh my god!
Kyo!
You'll be doing a concert, which is even better!
Well, it's not on Valentine's Day.
But it's the day before Valentine's Day, my 3D jazz show.
Tickets IRL are sold out, but there are tickets.
Oh, I think I forgot to write haunting.
Hold on.
There are tickets, streaming tickets that are still
available.
So, of course, they're still available.
They won't sell out.
I'm hunting now Oh yeah Looking so pretty today Thank you I
changed up a little bit Actually I'm in a lovey-dovey mood
Because I have I have a date Oh my god right after this Oh
my gosh You're probably like How What Yeah It's actually you
know Some people like Yeah, I have a...
A did...
So I did my hair up.
And I have my...
My usual...
Um...
Made outfit on.
Ooh.
Wow.
Yeah, I know.
Lucky.
I know.
Rico, thank you so much for the 50 gift to take you.
A did did did did.
Yeah, so once...
I'm gonna sing a few songs.
and then we'll see, you know...
My, my, my, my day!
I can't wait for your concert Vinto Valentine's karaoke
today is getting me even more hyped.
My red dress is ready.
My red dress is also ready.
Maybe.
I sound like an old man.
I'm going on a day!
Already pre-ordered your concert merch.
Thank you.
Date with my fave ghostly.
Yeah.
I want everybody to always feel like you guys are so loved.
I'm turning another year older on Valentine's Day, but since
you'll be busy and you're already singing now, might I get a
happy birthday?
Looking forward to the concert.
I'll be watching the bottom of my party.
What?
Skeletons, happy birthday.
Happy early birthday.
Yippee!
Um, what was I gonna say?
Oh, though, you guys, did you guys see that there's a state
of play on Thursday?
And...
There's a state of play on Thursday, and...
There's rumors of both DMC and Metal Gear?
I might have to try and fit in a street.
I might have to try and fit in a watch-along.
If I can.
If I have internet, I will do so.
Even though it's the day before my concert.
But it's only an hour long, so whatever.
I just won't scream.
I'll just be like, yeah, yeah, yeah, if anything is
announced.
Couldn't make it to the Valentine's concert, but we're going
to go to the Carrier Con concert.
Melody, thank you.
I'll see you there.
That's just next month.
Oh my gosh, so many concerts.
So many concerts.
He might scream.
I can't!
I literally have to preserve my voice for the jazz.
I'm rather fond of this ghost maid.
Yeah, my whisper screaming.
My whisper screaming.
Okay, I'm going to take a sip.
Let's start with a little something something, right?
A little something, something.
Let's see.
Hold on.
I choose to choose you happy Valentine's.
Yippee.
Just came back from the future, she will scream.
No, I won't.
Oh my gosh.
Cash money from my.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift and thank you.
Thank you.
What the heck?
Thank you so much.
I do have a bit of a set list, but I'm also, I'm also open
to some songs.
Oh my gosh.
Holy loud for me.
Hold on.
I'm adjusting things real quick.
Okie dokie.
Yeah, let's start with the first song, right?
Let's start with the first song, maybe.
A warm-up.
I didn't warm up.
Let's check it.
Let me make sure it's not too loud.
L is for the way you look at me O is for the only one I see
V is very, very extraordinary E is even more than anyone
that you adore And love is all that I can give to you Love
is more than just a game for two Two when love can make it
Take my heart and please don't break it Love was made for me
and you Yeah!
that I can give to you.
Love is more than just a game for two.
Two in love can make it take my heart and please don't break
it.
Love was made for me and you.
Oh!
Wait, oh, I should have like a little set listing, right?
Hold on.
Um.
One.
Hello.
Wait.
I just realized you guys couldn't see how ridiculous I was
spelling that.
Yippee!
And Draco, thank you so much for that, Tawariya, dude!
And, and, and, and...
Akashachi!
Thank you for the time, dude!
Thank you, thank you!
That was good!
Was it good?
Yay.
Oh, Valentine's Day.
so lovely and all the restaurants are full and all the
locations are busy and all i want is tacos but we're gonna
go see the mortuary assistant together right guys for
valentine's day we're gonna go see the mortuary assistant
movie tacos thinking of strange love Are we?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, it looks so scary.
You guys, I saw a review on it.
Oh my gosh, I saw a review.
And apparently, hold on, I'm tapping into my past brain.
But apparently, from the review that I saw, the guy
described it as what the Silent Hill movie thought it was.
And that, oh my gosh, it has a, oh, oh, I remember the
practical effects artist from the scariest story.
to tell in the dark movie he does the practical effects in
the mortuary assistant movie yeah and it's the same guy who
made terrifier i'm i'm afraid the game wasn't so gory but it
is like a little like you know obviously you're you're you
are you are uh what's the sound um embalming bodies so i've
heard that the bodies look quite realistic which is Pretty
freaky.
Phil, thank you so much for the peek.
Thanks for making these last 10 months amazing.
Thank you.
If you can eat popcorn during that, I will bow down to you.
I feel like popcorn.
If I were eating a burger, maybe no.
But popcorn, I probably could eat anytime.
It's popcorn.
I think it's fine I'm excited I want to see it But I think I
will be so scared And not sleep ever again I even want to
see it so bad We should do a watch along When it comes to
like a streaming Right?
Can we do a watch along instead?
I want to see it Let's watch it together Let's watch it
together Let's do another song this one I also wrote down
what's another name like two love songs Valentine's songs
mmm mmm mmm mmm mmm love fool that's a good one
oh by myself are you okay lover girl that's a good one too
i've been thinking about that song lately love a girl
okay let's do lover girl i actually picked a couple songs
that i like don't sing often or i have not sung before for
this karaoke.
So that's kind of fun.
That's kind of fun.
Leve, I love you.
The skyscrapers causing vertigo.
The countdown begins in Tokyo.
27 days alone means 20 million ways to cope without you.
I'm in a reckless weaver, love-struck girl, I tease her,
thought I'd never be her, quite the job you've done on me,
sir, you've been hosting parties, in my mind I'm working
over time to have you in my world, oh what a curse it is to
be a lover girl.
Oh, I ran out of breath.
Forced to get creative, wrote my feelings down.
The independent lady in me is nowhere to be found.
I can't wait another day to see you.
How embarrassing to be this way.
I'm in a reckless fever.
Love struck a light teaser.
ever be her quite the job you've done on me sir you've been
hosting parties in my mind i'm working over time to have you
in my world oh what a curse it is to be in love i wait by
the phone like a high school movie dream at the shows you'll
come running to me I see you in the wings, God, I'm
hallucinating.
What a reckless fever, love-struck girl, I tease her.
Thought I'd never be her, quite the job you've done on me,
sir.
You've been hosting parties, in my mind I'm working.
Over time you've become my whole world.
Oh, what a curse it is to be a lover girl.
Love a girl.
Yay, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
I love that song.
I love Leve.
Actually, it was very hard for the jazz show to not pick so
many Leve songs.
there's only one regrettably so i'll be attending the minto
with love lay show on my birthday weekend thank you for
being the silly little ghost in our lives i do not wait do
not wish me a happy birthday it is it is it your birthday
hagoon lagoon is it your birthday thank you for the rose
hello minto and i've was like you so sorry emily Don't worry
about it.
Don't worry about it.
Do we wish a not happy birthday?
Do we wish a
unhappy birthday?
Dramatic zoom.
Boom.
Do we wish a sad birthday?
But we should sing happy songs.
I'm going on my date.
is shining and the birds are singing you
know we should be celebrating we should be celebrating
Saturday is my birthday Valentine's birthday you were born
wait Were you born out of a chocolate box?
Were you born as a little chocolate?
That's me.
I'm the bird.
Sorry, I didn't warm up either.
Do people still give those hearts that have like the really
awkward like exo-exo-gossip girl.
Those ones, those, they taste terrible.
They're like chalk.
Yeah, the chalky hearts.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, they're so bad.
I once told this before, but mine's on the 15th.
No, I won't be around on the 15th.
Happy early birthday.
Happy Valentine's Day, Minto!
Happy Valentine's Day!
Oh, when I once was in ghoul school And it was Valentine's
Day I did not go to the school Don't, yes, I did go to the
school I did not go to the store And buy pre-made
Valentine's cards No, no, no I I Myself made my own in
PowerPoint And I Made them cryptid themed
And so everybody in my class got cryptid like Bigfoot.
And there
was something else.
I know I made one that was like, I'm skunk ape over you.
Mothman.
Yes, yes, yes.
I can't remember the other ones.
I just remember the Skunkade one.
They were all Metal Gear themed, I wish.
And then they had, like, the pictures of the cryptids.
Not them.
Oh, so silly.
So silly.
But, you know, everybody, it's a school of ghosts, so.
Probably.
Probably are expecting that, right?
Cryptid Valentine's Kid glitch face Would have been yearned
after you forever I did not have many friends Happy
Valentine I made this cookie for you Don't get the wrong
idea But back Thank you That would work on me for sure
Really Thank you, Taki Thank you Birthday gift to myself for
Friday is a minke jazz yeah minke jazz let's sing um i don't
actually did i write any other well we just did a jazz song
we just did lover girl that's a jazz song uh let's do this
one this is how this is what you can say to the date i think
the perfect cover song doki or you could sing is scottie
doesn't know wait i know that song but i don't know that
song Minta has been destined to be a monster Musume since
she was in school.
Maybe.
Here, let's sing.
I threw a wish in a well.
Don't ask me, I'll never tell.
I looked to you as it fell, and now you're in my way.
I trade my soul for a wish, pennies and dimes for a kiss.
I wasn't looking for this, but now you're in my way.
Your stare was holding ripped jeans, skin was showing night
wind was blowing where the wait oh hey i just met you and
this is crazy but here's my number so call me maybe it's
hard to look right at you baby but here's my number so call
me maybe hey i just met you and this is crazy but here's my
number so call me maybe and all the other boys Try to chase
me But here's my number So call me maybe I took your time
with the call I took no time with the fall You gave me
nothing at all But still you're in my way I beg and borrow
and steal At first sight and it's real I didn't know I would
feel it But it's in my way Your stare was holding Rip, jean,
skin was showing Hot night wind was blowing Where you think
you're going, baby?
Hey, I just met you And this is crazy But here's my number
So call me maybe It's hard to look right At you, baby But
here's my number So call me maybe Hey, I just met you And
this is crazy But here's my number And all the other boys
try to chase me But here's my number, so call me maybe
Before you came into my life, I've missed you so bad I
missed you so bad, I've missed you so, so bad Before you
came into my life, I've missed you so bad And you should
know that I've missed you so, so bad My number?
1-800-I-BOO Of course For all your spaghetti needs Hard to
look right At you baby But here's my number 1-800-I-BOO Hey
I just met you And this is crazy But here's my number So
call me maybe And all the other boys Try to chase me But
here's my number So call me maybe My life missed you so bad.
I missed you so bad.
I missed you so so bad Before you came into my life, missed
you so bad and you should know that So call me maybe
Doop doop doop doop doop dooooo Call me maybe no call me
ninto
Calm?
Call?
What's this button do?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Is the video for that song, Yally?
Honestly, I don't remember.
Okay, I don't remember the video.
I remember...
I remember the guys doing that dance on the bus or whatever.
Where they would, like, punch up in the air.
Can I get some spaghetti?
I need some to drop in front of a cute ghost girl.
You'll have to wait a couple hours.
It only comes at midnight.
It's Yowie at the end.
No way!
Our Oshiris.
In short, Oshiri.
Would have gotten me good.
Not the Oshiri.
Oshiri.
Got my streaming ticket.
Can't wait to see you on Friday.
You're going to question me, though.
Nashi, thank you.
Sayyidon, sayyidon, sayyidon, sayidon.
Hey, I just met you And this is crazy But here's my number
Call me, baby And all the other boys And I hate me Wait
a second
First ever proper Minto stream Gladys karaoke Welcome!
Welcome
Paul Larry Jepson, there was another song that she did
somewhat recently that was like, hold on, Carly, that I
liked.
It was like maybe a couple years ago or something, but she
had like a kind of a comeback.
D'Argo, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
Minto's Oshiri indeed gets all the eyeballs.
My Oshiri brings all the boys to the yard and they are like,
it's a better time in the yard.
I know, but she kind of like, you know, after calling me
maybe, I think people were like, oh, she is so overplayed.
I feel bad.
You know, I feel bad when like, when an artist goes viral
and it's like, um, it's like people get mad at them that
their song is unoverplayed, but it's not their fault.
You know, like it's not their fault that people are
listening to their stuff, right?
it's what do you do just want them to not put out music I
don't understand it burns out with the public yeah yeah it's
suffering from success truly truly there was one song though
I can't remember at all I remember seeing it like trending
though and people were like oh my gosh Carly Ray Jepson
she's so good again but
our Oshi Oishi Oshiri.
Why are we bringing up my Oshiri?
I like her album dedicated.
I haven't listened to a lot of her stuff, I'll be honest.
But I can't wait to see you on Friday.
Thank you!
I can't believe it's Friday.
I'm so nervous.
So, so, so, run away.
Hold on.
I'm going to listen to it real quick.
Run away.
It might have been that one.
Oh my gosh.
Me-do-do.
Listen to the, with the vocals.
I don't know what, I don't think.
I might know it if I hear her, or like hear her singing it.
Body,
body.
I don't know.
Wait, let me hear the chorus.
Aloha, thank you!
Gravity.
Thank you so much for the hot guys who put up for your at
all the concert verge watching a katsukan but karaoke stream
is a buzz birthday birthday happy birthday gravity that's a
sad song we're singing a love song
this isn't the one i was thinking of but it's good oh yeah
get it get it not carly get it person on caro fun yeah get
it person on caro fun yeah Yeah, I'll try and learn it for
the future.
Sounds good.
I wish I'd listen to more of her stuff, right?
Let's do this one.
I'm sorry, today I mostly only picked English songs.
I hope you guys don't mind.
I mostly only picked English songs.
I was like, I don't know what I was thinking.
I just did it.
I don't know.
Whatever.
It's fine.
This song, thank you very much.
Twilight movies.
Oh!
Scare me so much.
I forgot that I had the...
I forgot I had the lead vocal on!
Oh my god, that scared me.
Okay, redo.
Redo.
Heartbeats.
Fat.
colors and promises how to be brave how can I love when I'm
afraid to fall but watching you stand alone all of my doubt
suddenly goes away somehow One step closer I have died every
day waiting for you Darling, don't be afraid I have loved
you for a thousand years I love you for a thousand more
Still, beauty in all she is.
I will be brave.
I will not let anything take away, but standing in front of
me.
Every breath, every hour has come to this.
One step closer I have died every day waiting for you
Darling, don't be afraid I have loved you for a thousand
years I love you for a thousand more All along I believed I
would find you Time has brought your heart to me I have
loved you for a thousand years I love you for a thousand
more
One step closer Oh wait, I did the wrong one.
One step closer.
I have died every day waiting for you.
Darling, don't be afraid.
I have loved you for a thousand years.
I love you for a thousand more.
And all along I believed I would find you Time has brought
your heart to me I have loved you for a thousand years I
love you for a thousand more
Yeah Oh my gosh It's like the twilight song
Yeah, hard yearning song We're yearning, we're yearning
Let's see Let's do Some more high energy ones Let's see Oh,
oh, oh, I did this one because Doki just put out a cover for
it like yesterday day before yesterday day before yesterday
girlfriend this is a love is this a love song I don't know
actually is it no whatever I don't like your girlfriend I
think you need a new one
you're so fine I want your mind I think you're all about the
time you're so addicted Don't you know what I couldn't do to
make it with Alright, I can't speak Don't pretend I think
you know I'm damn precious Hell yeah, I'm the motherfucking
princess I can tell you like me too and you know I'm right
She's like, so whatever You could do so much better I think
we should get together now And that's what everyone's
talking about
I think you need a new one
I can see the way I see the way you look at me And even when
you look away I know you think of me I know you talk about
me all again and again Why are you tripping over?
Come over here and tell me what I want to hear Better yet,
make your girlfriend disappear I don't want to hear you say
her name ever again
Like so, whatever You could do so much better I think we
could get together now And that's what everyone's talking
about Our way, I think you need a new one I can be your
girlfriend I
know it's not a secret I wanna be your girlfriend In a
second, you'll be wrapped around my finger Cause I can,
cause I can do it better Gonna sink in She's so stupid, what
the hell were you thinking?
In a second, you'll be wrapped around my finger Cause
I'm through when it's gonna sink in She's so stupid, what
the hell were you thinking?
Hey, hey, you, you, I don't like your girlfriend No way, no
way I don't you need a new one I could
I think you need a new one I could be your girlfriend
I don't let you like me
I thought I was going to be doing the background ad libs.
I thought I was going to be like, no way.
Girlfriend.
Woo!
That song's so fun.
Yippee!
Oh, someone said love fool earlier, right?
Let me do that.
Love fool before I forget.
Wait, there's a bossa nova version?
Wait, what does this sound like?
Facing a problem, you love me no.
And maybe there is nothing that I can do.
Oh, this sounds nice.
Mama tells me I shouldn't bother that I ought just stick
to...
Wait, is this a love song or...
She deserves to be But I think you do So I cry And I pray
And I beg Love me, love me Say that you love me Fool me,
fool me Go on What is the key here?
Hold on, I need to hear it with like the vocal-ish Because
now I'm confused I cry and I pray And I beg Love me, love me
See that you love me Fool me, fool me Go on and fool me Love
me, love me Pretend that you love me Leave me, leave me Just
say that you need me So I cry And I beg for you to love me
Love me, love me Say that you love me, leave me, leave me
Just say that you need me I can't care about anything by you
All could spend my nights awake Wait, I can't get this verse
every...
What I could have done in another way to make...
It's too long!
Reason will not lead to solution I will end up lost in
confusion I don't care if you...
It's too long!
As long as you don't go So I cry and I pray and I beg Love
me, love me Say that you love me Fool me, fool me Go on and
fool me Love me, love me Pretend that you love me Leave me,
leave me Just say that you need me So I cry And I beg for
you to love me, love me Say that you love me Leave me, leave
me Just say that you need me about anything but you Love me,
love me Say that you love me Fool me, fool me Go on and fool
me Love me, love me I know that you need me I can't care
about anything but you
Thank you Someone asked about the Scotty Doesn't Know song
earlier, and I don't know it, I'm sorry.
Thank you for the super chat, I'm sorry, I don't know it.
And also, boss returns from hospital tomorrow, so no more
Minky in the warehouse.
Hey, Fatafeev, thank you so much.
Oh my goodness, for the big Arca don't know.
Thank you, Arca Supa, thank you.
At least your lovely, lovely day karaoke is here to soften
the blow.
Lay all your love on me by Abba.
That's a love song.
Wait, how does that go again?
The ghost is your emotion.
I don't remember.
I only know the chorus, I think.
They are your love.
Hold on.
Let me listen to it.
Let me see if I remember.
They are your love.
I don't know
if I remember it, but I'll try
I wasn't jealous before we met Now every woman I see is a
potential threat Oh, I kind of remember it, oh my gosh, wait
And I'm possessive, it isn't nice Wait, what's the, wait,
hold on, I'm saying what the vocals One thing is my only
vice But now it isn't true Now everything is new And all
I've ever learned has overturned I beg of you
Don't go wasting your emotion Lay all your love on me
It was like shooting a sitting duck A little small talk, a
smile, baby I was struck I still don't know what you've done
with me A grown-up woman should never fall so easily I
remember I feel the kind of fear When I don't have you near
I skip my pride, I beg you dear Don't go wasting your
emotion Lay all your love on me Don't go sharing your
devotion All your love on me Yeah!
No other Oshis.
Nah, I'm just kidding.
Unless.
They've been pretty scarce.
I used to think that was sensible.
It makes the truth even more incomprehensible.
Because everything is new.
And everything is you.
Burn has overturned.
What can I do?
Don't go wasting your emotion.
Lay all your love on me.
Don't go sharing your devotion.
emotion.
Lay all your love on me.
Don't go wasting your emotion.
Don't go sharing your devotion.
Lay all your love on me.
Don't go wasting your emotion.
Yay, yay, yay, yay.
That song is so fun.
Sorry that I couldn't remember the very beginning and then I
remembered it.
Wait, did I do something after girlfriend or before wait
What did I do what did I sing wait hold on Oh love fool kind
of oh kind of and then Lay all your love on me I have some
songs that I want to sing it's not my birthday today but my
birthday is on the 14th the floating brick happy early
birthday so many birthdays on the 14th wow oh oh love oh
sorry i have like a set list i'm sorry i don't know that
wait love the ceremony was that the i'm not gonna write you
a love song is that that one
i feel bad for whoever unless was four I'm not gonna let you
I only know the chorus I think Love song Cause he wears four
ways Cause he needs one And then I'm not gonna let you Wait
okay I'm gonna try and sing this song Um
Is this I don't know if this is a love song But I decided it
On it anyway
I want you to want me Oh Wait I want you to want me oh wait
i have i'm sorry i think i won't be taking any more requests
guys so please don't send please don't i feel so bad if you
send us a super chat i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
Alex do you do you do you thank you so much for the thank
you thank you thank you
um yeah I was taking some earlier because honestly I had
trouble thinking of songs I will do that one though okay
that's the last one I do wait that's the last request I will
do I'm sorry because i know that one but don't i do that one
yeah yeah yeah okay i just feel bad i feel bad trash ball
thank you so much for the podcast dude
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah i need
you and i need me
You're gonna need me I'd love you to love me I'll shine up
early, oh brand shoes Put on a brand new shirt I'll get home
early from work If you say that you love, oh say that you
love me Didn't I?
Didn't I?
Didn't I see you crying Didn't I?
I see you crying
Oh, didn't I?
Didn't I?
Didn't I see you crying I want you to want me I need you to
need me Got
the old brown shoes Put on a brand new shirt I'll get home
early from work If you say that you love me Didn't I?
Didn't I?
Didn't I see you crying?
Oh, didn't I?
Didn't I?
Didn't I see you crying Feeling all alone without a friend,
you know you feel like dying Oh, didn't I?
Didn't I?
Didn't I see you crying I
can still hear the girls screaming for the library, me too
Feeling all alone without a friend, you know you feel like
dying and i didn't i didn't i see you crying
want you to want me i need you to need me
yeah yay yeah yeah yeah yeah uh want you to wait that's
right yeah want you to want me Okie dokie.
Okie dokie.
This is also...
a...
Valentine's song.
Steiner, get off the official account.
Steiner!
Get off the account right now.
Go away.
also wait did you guys see that it's not a wrench anymore
what is that it's like a little shield you must oh my queen
you must uh i will protect you your the mean comments but
we'll get through my shield before before they reach your
precious eyes
The Defender of the Faith.
Steiner, no steining.
My princess, I am your knight.
I am your knight.
And I will defend you from the evil comments.
Such as...
Face reveal.
It's the only thing I could think of for like a VTuber
spammer.
Godfrey, thank you so much for the part I get there.
Would you like to see my face?
VTuber face reveal in 3, 2, 1.
Wait, wait, I should have...
Wait, I'm such an idiot!
Hold on.
VTuber face reveal in 3, 2, 1.
Wait.
Hold on.
Hold on, hold.
Wait.
Hold.
No.
You saw nothing?
Wait.
Oh!
I have an even better idea!
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, ready?
Wait.
Face reveal.
Three, two, one.
Hi.
I'm dream.
Eye blue on the brain.
Thank you so much for the time.
He gets it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, she's cute.
She's so pretty cute!
I want you to want me!
That's me doing the version with all the ladies screaming.
Anyway.
This is a Valentine's song though.
Invisible Buzz!
Thank you so much for the Tech Gifted!
Five, six, five, six, seven, eight
I could be your one or your new addiction It's all in my
head, but I want nonfiction I don't want this world, but
I'll take this city Who can blame a girl?
Call me hot, not pretty Baby, do you like this beat?
I made it so you dance with me 99 degrees When you're doing
it with me Doing it with me H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and
touch your toes Raise your hands now body roll Dance it out,
you're hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your
toes Raise your hands, no body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can
take me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go
Well, I woke alone tearing at my ceiling I try not to care,
but it hurts my feelings You don't have to stare, come here,
get with it No one's touched me there in a damn heart, man
in a baby Don't you like this beat?
I made it so you'd sleep with me It's like 199 degrees When
you're doing it with me I'm doing it with me.
H-O-T-T-O-G-O Snap and clap and touch your toes Raise your
hands now body roll Dance it out, you're hard to go
hands now body roll H-O-T-T-O-G-O H-O-T-O-G-O You can take
me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go
What's it take to bring you home?
Hurry up, it's time for supper Order up, I'm hard to go
What's it take to get your number?
Hurry up, it's getting cold Hurry up, it's time for supper
Order up, I'm hard to go
H-O-T-T-O-G-O You can take me hard to go H-O-T-T-O-G-O You
can take me hard to go It's hot in the air.
Is anyone else hot?
Okay.
I'm...
Yeah, hot to go.
Hot to go!
Yippee!
It's actually pretty comfortable.
I'm the only one sweating here.
Even though my pits are out.
I just be sweating.
They do be sweating.
Oh my gosh, I got a tea.
That's like a honey lemon tea.
But it's kind of like jam, so I use scoop it, right?
And it has bits of lemon in it so I can eat the peel.
Minky Kyota!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
The set list grows smaller.
which means there's more songs i chose this one but actually
i'm like do i know how this song goes
wait do they even have it
oh my god oh wait wait let me share how this sounds i
believe the christmas lights up till january
This sounds like Taylor, no?
Doesn't this sound like Taylor?
Okay, I'm gonna try.
This sounds just like her.
Holy cow.
It might be Taylor.
Uh-oh, I'm gonna get, I'm gonna get, I'm gonna get my
channel terminated.
Yikes, okay.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Steiner.
I'll, I'll pin that.
I'll pin that.
Thank you, Densetsu.exe official YouTube channel that has,
uh, uh, Densetsu.exe official song Densetsu MVP is that
everybody should be listening to.
right right right right okay I'll try this song
we do another song I'll pick something else
we could leave the Christmas lights up till January and this
is our place we make the rules there's a time Hazling haze,
a mysterious way about you, dear.
Have I known you 20 seconds for 20 years?
Can I go and wear
me always?
Be this close, forever and ever, love.
Take me out, take me home.
My, my, my lover
We could let our friends cash in the living room This is our
place, we make the call And I'm highly suspicious that
everyone who sees you wants you I've loved you Maybe I don't
know the song I think I think I just realized what this is
You know when people like You know when people like Take
songs and then like cut the Use like a program to like Cut
down the song I think that's what that is
I'm gonna get it so Copyright YouTube Don't listen please
Oh my god I think that was like actually like her actual
song Yeah like a bot to filter the voice out Yeah yeah yeah
because you can hear it kind of being like Like a little
alien in the background
But that was Lover by Taylor Swift Sorry actually I'll do
another song
I'll do another song I'm so sorry that that one because I
was like this doesn't sound right it sounds strange but also
I don't think I knew it so well
wait let me make sure I got the right one
okay this one though I like this one unchained memory
melody.
That's that one.
Wait, I think I think I know it.
Hold on.
Let me hit listen to it first.
Oh, that one's good.
Yeah.
Wait, let me turn it up.
It's a key.
Let me make sure.
Hold on.
I'm trying to get the key right for me.
Oh, I'll do plus two okay all right yeah this one's good
i've never sung it on karaoke before so okay cool cool
yuppie okay and play
oh longer for your touch how long Lonely time
Goes by So slowly And I can do So much Are you Still mine
I need your love
God, speed your love to me.
The rivers flow to the sea, to the sea, to the open arms of
the sea.
Lonely riverside, wait for me.
wait for me I'll be coming home wait for me whoa lonely
time and time goes by so slowly and time I can do so much
Are you still mine?
I need your love
I need God's be your love.
me
yay wait i haven't heard that song in so long i feel like i
got the end wrong wait hold on i'm gonna listen to it real
quick like it felt so epic for how like oh he goes so high
uh oh he does like i need your love oh i forgot so my bad i
I was like low the entire time.
That's okay.
Minto version.
Yeah, minto version.
Guys, look at the time.
I think it's time for my date.
I'm so excited.
I can't wait to go.
So thank you for listening to my karaoke.
And oh.
Oh, wait a second.
Wait.
Yeah, uh, yeah, thank you for listening to my karaoke and,
um, oh, oh, one second, one second.
I think I need to take this.
One second.
Hello?
Yes, I know, I'm so excited.
Oh.
You can't?
Do you want to reschedule or no?
Oh.
Oh, no, it's okay.
I, I, um...
No, I had other plans tonight, too.
Yeah.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, thank you.
Um.
No, yeah.
Oh.
Have fun.
Okay.
Yep.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, I didn't think it would work out.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Guys, I hate Valentine's Day.
I hate Valentine's Day.
I I don't want to sing love songs anymore I don't want to
sing love songs anymore
Sad songs only Sad songs only
Maybe this time I'll be lucky Maybe this time he'll stay
Maybe this time for the first time Love won't hurry away.
It will hold me...
Wait, how does this part go?
Wait, all I need is a little...
Less...
No, wait, why is my thing not a loser?
Any more like the last time.
And the time.
Before Oh, this time
Everybody Loves a winner So nobody loved me Lady peaceful
Lady happy That's what I longed to be.
When odds, the odds are, they're in my favor, something's
bound to begin.
It's gotta happen, happen sometime, maybe this time I'll
win, cause everybody, oh, friend I'm the winner, so nobody
loved me.
Lady peaceful, lady happy, that's what I long to be.
All the odds are, they're in my favor.
Something's bound to begin.
It's gonna happen, happen so time We'll be this time, we'll
be this time Oh, we'll be...
My thing working.
Hold on.
No more happy songs, only sad songs.
That was called Maybe This Time.
Wait, one second.
Oh, there we go.
It's okay, Minto.
Is it really?
Is it okay?
I had a date.
I had a date also canceled for your concert.
This was peak karaoke.
This happened to be last year on Valentine's after being
single for a year and then she canceled.
No!
For all of us saddies, we sing the sad karaoke songs.
of the ones that got away but for those of us who do not
have a valentine
i saw your green hair a beauty mark next to your mouth
they're on the subway i nearly had a breakdown a few weeks
later somebody wore your perfume it almost killed me I had
to leave the room, it's just another day And it's not over,
till it's over, it's never over It's just another day, and
it's not over, till it's over And it's never over, till I
don't look for you on the stairs Or wish you thought that we
were still soulmates But I'm still counting down all of the
days Till you're just another girl on the subway Made you
the villain, evil for just moving on I see your shadow, I
see it even more With the lights off, I made a promise If in
reds this feeling ain't gone Well, fuck this city, I'm
moving to Saskatchewan It's just another day And it's not
over, till it's over, till it's over It's just another day,
and it's not over Till it's over, it's never over Till I can
break routine during foreplay And trust myself that I won't
say your name But I'm still counting down all of the days
Till you're just another girl on the subway She's got away.
She's got away.
And she got, she got away.
She got away.
She's got, she's got away.
She's got away.
And she got, she got, she got away, she got away, she got
away, she got away.
She's got, she's got away, she's got away.
She's got away She's got away She's got, she's got away
She's got away She's got away And she got, she got away She
got away She got away
What am I supposed to do?
We'll go see the mortuary assistant.
That was the subway.
I'm still not feeling over it, though.
She's got a wisp.
Break a leg this week and I'm so proud of you.
Thank you.
Happy, happy Valentine's Day.
I mean, so happy.
Arigato, Arigato, too.
Random eye, bro.
Looking forward to the concert.
Thank you for the karaoke.
Thank you.
uh oh thank you so much for the for the for the for the oh
for the thank you thank you i have another song i want to
sing wait okay
um wait one second
oh oh oh there we go wait hold on i gotta pull up the lyrics
for this one uh i have to pull up the lyrics for this one
wait actually when does it come in wait sorry one second
wait let me see let me listen wait actually does this have
it hold on wait everybody hold hold
Hold.
Does my hair looks funny like this, you guys?
I cut it off in a, in a, in a sad, in a sad rage.
You like it?
Break up hair.
It's cute.
You like it.
It looks kind of different, right?
from how i my hair is i feel usually a little fluffier but
now it's like no it's so fluffy
can we get a bullet why why are you asking for a bullet what
the heck what the heck one second sorry i'm still figuring
this out um
Oh, okay, never mind.
I'm good.
This song, wait, I just, I did this earlier song called
Maybe This Time, but this song is just called Maybe.
Maybe.
Bullet is Big Boss's hairstyle in MGS 3.
Yeah, but why, why, I don't, I don't want to, I don't want
to look like him.
I don't want to look like him.
Okay, okay.
Maybe I'll see you at Christmas Maybe I'll see you at New
Year's Maybe I'll laugh like you never felt When I see you
again in two years Maybe I'll all be different Maybe your
hair will be shorter Maybe we won't even talk anymore When
we're older, I'll be missing you Every minute you aren't
here The future isn't clear Oh, oh, maybe All we have is
maybe, maybe Oh, I'll see you again Oh, maybe, all we have
is maybe, maybe All else is...
This is not the end of...
Maybe one day I'll get married And you'll be my maid of
honor And during your toast, you'll make everyone cry And
I'll finally see tears from my father Maybe our kids will be
best friends We'll live down the street from each other And
maybe I'll smile because your daughter laughs like her
mother I'll be missing you Every minute you are in tears The
future isn't clear Oh, maybe All we have is maybe Maybe I'll
I'll see you again Oh, maybe All we have is maybe Maybe,
maybe, oh, this is not the end And maybe it is and that's
okay
This isn't goodbye It's see you again See you again This
isn't goodbye It's see you again See you again All we have
is maybe Maybe I'll I'll see you again
Maybe.
That was a maybe.
By Gabriella Bee.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you for the claps.
I'm not crying.
You are.
No, don't cry.
Don't cry.
Yay.
Maybe you can be our Valentine's.
Can we?
Can we be Valentine's?
Okay, collect.
Look to your eyeball to your left.
Look to the eyeball to your right.
Your Valentine.
Look to the eyeball above you.
Below you.
What are they doing down there?
No, but never can't.
cancel a date though with me though you're gonna kill it at
the concert such a stacked line up wish i could be there but
i'll be there in spirit thank you thank you thank you i will
do my very very bestest i'm so nervous though i'm so nervous
i'm so nervous all right i intended on today's stream being
a little bit shorter so i do only have 15 songs so I have
just two songs left you know it is I wanted to do karaoke
usually I go like pretty longer but I wanted to not sing so
much since I do have a concert later this later this week so
yes yes yes yes only 15 isn't that a lot or I mean not a lot
I mean because usually I do like 20 plus
you are doing great thank you yeah 15 is a good amount yeah
you know even if you don't have somebody for Valentine's Day
even if you maybe had somebody and then not anymore or maybe
you have somebody for valentine's day i hope regardless your
situation that you have a fun day and treat yourself and
take it easy and honestly it's honestly just a day like any
other day so don't you worry about it don't you worry your
precious little head
yeah yeah yeah and like how days are they start and they end
so if you're like man valentine's day everybody's talking
about it it too shall pass don't you worry yes yes yes let's
see this is but we're still in our sad era i have one more
sad era song wait let me hear how this one starts again too
i'm doing all these like new songs and they're all like i'm
getting i'm getting what's it called um i'm getting all nerf
uh i'm getting all tripped up from them
hold on um
i think i remember how this goes i'll do my best okay next
song is wildflower by billy eyelash
Things fall apart And time breaks your heart I wasn't there
but I know She was your girl You showed her the world But
fell out of love And you both let go She was crying on my
shoulder All I could do was hold her Only made us closer
Until July Now I know that you love me You don't need to
remind me I should put it all behind me Shouldn't I?
But I see her In the back of my mind All the time Like a
fever Like I'm burning alive Like a sign Did
I cross the line?
Things don't last and life moves so fast I'd never ask who
was better Cause she couldn't be more different than me
Happy and free in leather And I know that you love me When I
put it all behind me But maybe I see her In the back of my
mind All the time Just like a fever Like I'm burning alive
Like a sign
Did I cross the line?
I'm staying
crying in the hotel I know you didn't mean to hurt me So I
kept it to myself And I wonder, do you see her?
back of your mind in my eyes.
You say no one knows you so well, but every time you touch
me, I just wonder how she felt.
Valentine's Day, crying in the hotel.
I know it didn't mean to hurt me, I kept it to myself.
Yay!
That was wildflower.
I did my best.
I forgot some parts, but that's okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The last song, let's, let's, you know what?
What, what is all of this?
What is all of this being sad and moping?
No!
Bring out the sunshine!
Bring it out again!
Bring it out!
No more being sad, no more moping.
Bring out the sunshine, bring out the sunshine.
Oh, my mic is so funky.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, pink.
Need,
we don't need a Valentine.
We can have fun all on our own.
Yeah.
I got to work overtime on Valentine's Day so the couples get
the day off and use their leftover vacation on their kids
winter break.
No!
Wait that's so stinky.
That's so stinky!
No.
You got chocolates for us?
Maybe.
Put your hands into the big sky.
do your best I hope I hope I hope it's not too hard of work
maybe maybe less people there will be more chill all right
maybe all right I have one last song I don't I don't know if
you'd consider it I don't know if you'd consider it a love
song or what but um one second
uh wait a second
all right I'm gonna do this is also a new song that i've
never sung before so i'm going to do my best with it too
okey-dokey one last song thank you guys for karaoke today
thank you thank you one last song one last song can i
suggest lover girl by levi frankie you might want to look at
number two in the set list yippee all right here we go
Oh You said your phone was broken just forgot to charge it
Whole outfit you were wearing, God I hope it's ironic Did
you just say you're finished?
Didn't know we started It's all just so familiar, baby What
do you call it?
Stupid!
Or is it?
Slow!
Maybe it's...
useless but there's a cuter word for it I know man child why
you always come up running to me fuck my life won't you let
an innocent woman be never heard of self-care half your
brain just ain't there man child And
taking all my loving from me
Why so sexy if so dumb And how survive the earth so long If
I'm not there it won't get done I choose to blame your mom
And child Why you always come up running to me Fuck my life
Won't you let an innocent woman be Never heard of self-care
Half your brain just ain't there And child Why you always
come running Taking all my loving from me Like my boys are
waiting and hard to get And I like my men are all
incompetent and i swear they choose me i'm not choosing them
amen amen oh i like my boys playing hard again and i like my
men all incompetent and i swear they choose me i'm not
choosing them
always come running to me.
Fuck my life.
Won't you let an innocent woman be?
Come, I'm singing, loving it.
And I lack competence.
I'm not choosing men.
Amen.
For
karaoke.
Thank you.
Happy Valentine's Day.
Oh.
Will you be my Valentine?
I'm Bigfoot over you.
Well, drink taco.
Thank you so much for the thought I got that.
Thanks for singing.
Thanks for listening.
Yes.
Okay.
Let's go get tacos.
Oh my gosh.
Don't go take your food.
Nodan, welcome to Bambu Show.
Thanks for the breathtaking Valentine's karaoke, Bito.
If a fool ever cancels on you, remember, you'll always have
us eyeballs and we all love you.
And don't let yourself stress too much.
The concert is going to be great and it will be phenomenal.
Good night.
Good night, everybody.
I'm begging you.
Thank you for the Hakusuba.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'll have my hair up properly next stream.
you know since it's since it's since i'm made out of goo
basically i can i could just if i like push it out you know
had me a big foot thank you everybody thank you thank you
bye bye bye thanks for listening bye bye bye
There was a Muppet special where Sabrina Carpenter sang the
song.
And then there's chickens in the background where it's like,
And I like my boys all incompetent.
That part when they go, In the background, and it's so cute.